cette attaque
[Musique]
l agression
notre mouvement
[Musique]
quoique certains
à nouveau à paris
ce travail est amicale
nombreux sujets d'actualité
internationale européenne et les
protections 6 auront à vivre ensemble en
slovénie à bruxelles
notre dernière visite à paris
une des maîtresses ou une candidate je
crois me
et mes
prières de la relation franco allemande
donc le match française il était notre
partenaire
évidemment
la
route mais
ce sujet nous discuterons aussi
évidemment de plusieurs autres régions
qui attendent la cohérence des européens
notre travail ensemble et la défense
d'une une vraie autonomie de l'europe
c'est vrai pour le sahel en matière de
terrorisme
sur notre voisinage oriental
la route et tous ces grands dossiers
d'y passer quelques temps madame la
chancelière et donc
renforcer les liens
sur la situation clinique
ambitions de
régulation du numérique
ils essaient
également de préparer les prochaines
créations
leurs auteurs et internationales
comme la conscience des échéances
politiques
chancelière angela merkel et moi même
continuerons
cherchons à apporter des solutions aux
méthodes
[Musique]
tout d'abord
présenté comme le décès
sa famille
vit dans une famille qui est très dur et
touchant
deux points à l'ordre du jour
de savoir ce que
nous avons vu
contre le
tfc
n'a pas permis d'aller les objectifs que
nous nous étions fixés
situation
de votre vision sur une jambe
pour arriver à faire des tours
difficiles et les progrès sont
faits parleront
[Musique]
des changements climatiques et
faillirent santé les gens
se sont excusés
[Musique]
difficile
aussi
profiteront alors dans son ensemble
[Musique]
là aussi nous avons beaucoup de
blessures
merci de cette habitation se donne merci
jungle
[Applaudissements]
bon
on tourne
toujours